hey guys i'm philip molina and this is a
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 6
episode 5 the door and it's the saddest
door ever and it is like just I wish
none of this had happened I feel bad for
getting everybody so excited about this
episode and then this is what I made you
guys get like have to deal with I'm all
torn up about the Hodor right now and in
fact I feel terrible for a number of
reasons so I don't totally have it in me
a second to do this breakdown I'm just
feeling so terrible
but I got my friend to come in Eric
Herrick hey everyone ok Pigman you don't
they push me I don't feel well enough to
do this but we had a big conversation
about it Eric is as big a fan of gaming
as I am he's read all the books knows
everything I would have said about this
anyway I'll be nice to him he's so
delicate see bruising I'm bruising and
he's just gonna take over just talking
about this episode for me as I leave and
try to get better but tweet at me fine
hey guys let's just all pray and send
Philip our warm thoughts so that he can
get better I'm real torn up just like
you are my mind is blown my heart is
broken I feel so bad about Hodor I'm
here with you we're gonna break down
everything this episode all the details
you might have missed implicitly that
this is ice cold Phillip is the night
king but no we're gonna go through this
together I got a couple predictions and
theories for what's coming up in
upcoming episodes but anyway let's get
right started with the opening images so
we see this close-up of Sansa sewing
leather into wolf fur now the last video
pointed out that Sansa is returning to
her old stark roots and sewing was a big
part of her life back in season one but
also by fusing together the wolf's fur
with this tough leather it's almost like
Sansa is mending the severed ties
between the Starks in the tough
unyielding northern families now check
out this wax mockingbird seal on the
letter from Littlefinger that's the seal
of the house Baelish and notice how it's
this reddish pinkish color that's
actually the same color on the wax seal
that was on the pink letter that we saw
last episode the reason I point that out
is if you watch our last video we kind
of break down the color of the wax on
the pink letter and how it's interesting
that it's this reddish pinkish color
when normally
in the past Ramsay has used this yellow
wax to seal his letters so I think it's
interesting that even though we were
left on this kind of uncertain place on
who wrote the pink letter right away
this episode begins with this red sigil
from a letter that Littlefinger wrote so
even though it's not totally confirmed I
feel like it's becoming a little more
likely that Littlefinger could be behind
this letter we move on to this meet-up
in moles town between Sansa and
Littlefinger now if you remember moles
town was this village near the wall that
was rated by the wildlands back in
season 4 and that's why it's all in
ruins now but notice how Littlefinger is
totally caught off guard in the scene
this is the most uncomfortable we've
ever seen him
Sansa calls him out with his icy guilt
trip we're marrying her to this abusive
monster Ramsay and Littlefinger tries to
defend himself by saying made a mistake
our of a mistake I underestimated a
stranger now if you remember in our last
episode we pointed out how the title of
the episode the book of the stranger was
referring to these parables that master
manipulators like the high Sparrow and
Littlefinger used to try to manipulate
people but it's totally not working here
Sansa isn't buying it this scene just
stretches on for what feels like a
lifetime for a little finger and the
editing is just like forcing him to
listen to it and even if you see this
perspective shot from Brienne sword you
can see that he's totally feeling like
he could die in this moment now quickly
I want to point out a couple things
about this conversation so Littlefinger
mentions Brendon blackfish that's
Caitlyn's uncle whom we haven't really
seen since the red wedding and I don't
know if we can totally trusts
Littlefinger here but if he is telling
the truth the show could finally be
picking up those loose threads with the
Tully family and if that's true we might
even see Caitlyn's brother Ed myrrh - I
hope the honeymoons been going well also
if you were wondering why Littlefinger
corrects himself your brother Johnny oh
brother this is just a little bigger
reminding Sansa that it's not gonna be
easy to rally all the stark bannermen to
a bastard like Jon Snow who's not a
trueborn stark okay moving on to Arya in
the wave sparring in the house of black
and white we get this parallel weapon
perspective shot of the bo staff like
the wait this threatening Arya just like
Brienne was threatening Littlefinger
back in moles town the way the ends is
fight by saying never be one of us lady
Stark
we've been saying before that this is
going to be the year of the stark and as
much as it seems like Arya is leaving
her family behind her training with the
faceless men keeps reminding her of
where she came from
Jackie Nagar explains the interesting
origin story of the faceless men they
begin as slaves in the mines of Illyria
soon all the Masters and overseers were
gone and the faceless men fled I founded
the free city of Braavos and built this
house and this actually happens
throughout the episode these characters
opening up doorways to the Past this
comes up a lot and all pointed out every
time it happens and right away we get
another door to the past with Arya
watching this play in Braavos and
remember she's reliving the exact moment
that she witnessed back in season one
her father's execution at Baylor she's
even perched higher than the rest of the
crowd to get a good look just like she
was back in that scene but notice how
she's learning that her perception of
what went down isn't at all what the
rest of the world saw Arya saw her
father as noble to a fault
and she saw Cersei and Joffrey as evil
Psychopaths but the world is simpler
takes on all these characters Ned to the
rest of the world is a gullible idiot
Joffrey is a mama's boy and Cersei is an
overprotective mom and it's interesting
that everyone assumes Tyrion is behind
all the events that happen so urging Ned
to take the throne no that was actually
Littlefinger the Train Ned with the
dagger to his throat also Littlefinger
paying off Ilyn Payne to execute Ned no
that was just Joffrey being a dick and
while all this was happening
Tyrion wasn't even in King's Landing but
the point of all this is that the truth
doesn't matter in this world all that
matters is whatever is the easiest story
to sell I'll touch on this again later
it's also interesting that after being
forced to forget about her bucket list
by jacking in the weights Joffrey Cersei
Walder Frey Meryn Trant Tywin Lannister
the red woman Arya is presented with
this opportunity to kill the actress
lady crane she plays Cersei the person
who's at the top of arias bucket list
here's why I don't think that's a
coincidence the idea of a play within a
play goes back to Shakespeare when
Hamlet stages a mock play about the
recent succession to the throne as a
test to see how someone in the audience
reacts I think that's exactly what
jacket is doing here he's making Arya
watch this false narrative hoping to
draw the truth out of her can Arya
complete the mission without her past
loyalties distracting her or will she
always be lady Stark and maybe it's just
the theater nerd inside of me but there
are all kinds of Shakespeare connections
in the scene the actors speak Tinh
rhymed couplets who will teach him grace
to whom we'll eat on when is
time to learn to look darkness in the
face there's this broad slapstick humor
there's live musicians playing the
balconies it all feels like this entire
set design was inspired by Shakespeare's
Globe Theatre in London and by the way
those musicians played up in the balcony
that's the band of Monsters and Men and
I'm sorry about all these Shakespeare
references I'm going to move on in a
second I promise but this whole section
reminds me of another famous Shakespeare
quote all the world's a stage and all
the men and women merely players
they have their exits and their
entrances and one man in his time plays
many parts so this is one of his most
famous extended metaphors and it refers
to the idea that life is just one great
performance Aria is witnessing the
events of her life as a literal
performance and also I want to point out
that that quote ends with the last scene
of all is mere oblivion to me that
sounds a lot like all men must die and
the last thing I want to point out about
the sequence is right after we see the
Sansa actresses bare breasts we get a
shocking cut to something that we
obviously can't show here but it's
interesting that along with Sansa sangre
speech about what Ramsay did to her this
show seems to be taking a more balanced
approach to sex and nudity
I'm sure Emilia Clarke is happy about
that it idles penis that's your big
cause he the penis okay let's move on to
brands imagery loaded vision so right
away the visuals are establishing a
connection between the children of the
forest and the White Walkers with these
Stonehenge like rocks formed in a spiral
pattern
remember back in season 3 the White
Walkers assembled all the dead horse
parts in the same kind of spiral so it
seems like they're doing this as a
reference to their place of origin and
this transformation scene reminded me of
that season 4 seen in another stonehenge
e-ring when the knight king transformed
the human baby into a white Walker this
event is the creation of the first white
Walker maybe even the night King I don't
know don't pull me to that whoever it is
it's the first white Walker
notice how leap is stabbing this guy
with the blade and that's obsidian
remember dragonglass it's one of the few
things that White Walkers are vulnerable
to and now it seems like we understand
why but I'm wondering who is this guy
it's not totally clear but he must be
special in some kind of way if the blade
that is sticking in his chest doesn't
kill him he could be a green seer like
bran or the three-eyed Raven or maybe he
just has some powers and some other kind
or maybe it's just a random dude
so leave kinda goes into why they're
doing this in the next scene but here's
a little background from the books so
ten thousand years ago or so there was a
war between the first men and the
children of the forest the war dragged
on for centuries and it led to some big
disastrous events like the children
before is shattering the land bridge
between Westeros and Essos it totally
changed geography of this world they
also invented these white weapons of
mass destruction and I'll get to the
worldly implications of that a little
later but this is interesting
because we're now learning that the
White Walkers aren't exactly the evil
incarnate that we used to think sure
they want to kill all men and turn their
bodies into white sand they steal our
babies so that's pretty evil obviously
but they didn't always exist they aren't
the otherworldly evil that's playing the
constant cosmic chess game with a world
of light or something like that
they're more like the Sentinels of x-men
or the terminators and the Terminator
movies they were created became sentient
and went far beyond what their intended
purpose was so they're evil in that way
but they're not totally indestructible
the other thing I want to point out
about this scene is this face carve into
the weirwood tree now all the weirwood
trees have faces carved into them that
was something that the children of the
forest did during the pact that they
made back in that or with men that I
mentioned before but this face in
particular looks so much like the
three-eyed Raven it's like they modeled
the carvings off of Max von Sydow space
you even have these roots that are
binding across the trunk of the tree
that looked like the roots that are
entangled with the three-eyed Raven so I
feel like this is the show again
underlining the fact that the three-eyed
Raven is the weirwood tree he's all the
weirwood trees he's someone who has
connection to all of history he can see
everything he knows everything he's just
the form of the weirwood trees that's
taken a human form okay then we move on
to this Kingsmoot election in the Iron
Islands
and notice how yara wants to be the
first female leader of a male-driven
society and just like another real world
woman running for office against a guy
who loves talking about his big dick
this election kind of plays out the same
way he referred to my hands of their
small something else must be small I
guarantee you there's no problem and I'm
going to get event right over and give
it to Daenerys Targaryen along with my
big [ __ ]
and I know before I was talking about
doors to the past we saw a brand go
through a door to the past to see the
creation of the first white Walker this
scene we see a different kind of door
the door between life and death when
your own great joy gets baptized his
brother damp hair drags them into the
water and forces him to actually drown
now we haven't seen this on the show
before but this is actually how people
in the Iron Islands baptize people they
pay tribute to the drowned God by
forcing their head underwater and
killing them for a second but he comes
back and he rises again harder and
stronger and those are actually the
exact words of the Ironborn and notice
how Euron's first move is to murder his
niece and nephew let's go good Yara made
the same threat now I know what my first
act as Queen will be to execute the man
who killed my father
so it's interesting how in Game of
Thrones no one has sends to a throne
without bloodshed you have to kill the
person currently on the throne and
anyone else who could possibly claim it
otherwise your rule is never secured
that's why Robert Baratheon wanted to
kill all the living Targaryen and why
Cersei had all of Roberts bastard
children murdered I should point out
that in the books the storyline to join
forces with Dany and marine is actually
led by a different Greyjoy brother who
doesn't look like he's gonna be in the
show
his name's Vic Tyrion that's kind of a
bummer that he's not gonna be in the
show because he's really a great
character but I think the show might be
splitting up the best parts of his
storylines yarn Theon and another
character that I'll talk about in a bit
but the last shot of neuron as he stands
before the sea separating him and Dany
immediately cuts to a shot of Dany as
she looks over the drained Dothraki sea
clearly the editing is bringing these
two characters together across the sea
there is a person who hates the great
Lords of Westeros just as much as we do
and together we're going to take the
Seven Kingdoms so we get this emotional
farewell between Daenerys and Jorah and
Daenerys commands them to heal yourself
Joris greyscale is another door between
life and death
clearly it's the mark of death and we've
seen what happens to other people will
get greyscale remember we've seen at
least one other character survive
greyscale Shireen Stannis his daughter
she was afflicted with the disease as an
infant and Spanish brought in healers
from both sides of the Narrow Sea to
stop the spread and they succeeded but
the greyscale permanently scarred her
face but the fact that the show could be
pointing that he's off on this search
for a cures means that
could have a full life ahead of them and
actually before we move on there's
another theory a hat for Joris grayscale
I'll admit it's a bit of a stretch but
it does connect to that Victorian
greyjoy character that I talked about
before there's a part to Victarion story
in the books where his hand gets wounded
in battle and a red priest uses magic to
make it charred and blackened it and it
stops the infection but it makes his
arms stronger than it ever was before
so if part of Joris search for a cure
involves a red priest it would be cool
to see his greyscale turning his Ashley
arm into this super Winter Soldier arm I
don't know that's gonna be the case but
we'll see be fun ok moving on so
remember before I talked about Tyrion
being the victim of the easiest story to
sell and now we see Tyrion selling his
own not really true narrative that
Daenerys is responsible for the peace
and marine and I think it's interesting
that when Varys asked who his PR person
will be Tyrion responds with a callback
to Varys his line last season who said
anything about him now this high priests
Eskin vara is basically the head of the
Lord of Light religion she has all these
titles and she definitely outranks
Melisandre but notice how she's wearing
the same kind of necklace Melisandre
wears we've seen other red priestesses
who don't wear that necklace so I wonder
if this high priestess is concealing old
age just like Melisandre was it's also
interesting that Tyrion would consider
putting a religious fanatic in a
position of power in Mereen remember
Cersei did the same thing in King's
Landing with high Sparrow and we saw how
well that worked out for her I wonder if
Tyrion will end up regretting this
decision hopefully he won't have to do a
walk of shame you might enjoy that I
don't know but the blocking of the scene
already hints that Tyrion might be
feeling overwhelmed last episode when
Tyrion placated the men of marine he
drove the conversation and they walked
down the steps to come to their level he
showed no fear but now he stays far away
from Kimbra at the top of the steps
letting her and Varys Duke it out while
he hides behind Varys conveyor then
rises up the steps to meet him this kind
of shows her rise to power already
and when Canberra tells Varys about his
abuse as a child she accomplishes two
things one she
totally breaks them out because I'm
pretty sure he's like hey Tyrion I only
told you about that so how is she
reading my mind right now this is
totally freaking me out and it's
interesting that we see another master
later just like Littlefinger totally
looked unnerved like these two guys are
arguably the cleverest people in the
show and nothing really surprises them
but in this episode both of them look
like oh [ __ ] you got a point there I
don't know what to say I should also
point out that this whole scene is
another example of a scene opening a
door to the past with a link to another
mysterious characters origin barracks
before I move on I want to talk about
this disagreement between red
priestesses conveyor believes that the
prince that was promised is Daenerys
Targaryen
but remember Melisandre believes it's
Jon Snow they both point to miracles as
evidence Daenerys was the unburnt mother
of dragons and Jon came back from the
dead after a prayer to the Lord of Light
and we predicted last video that this
could lead to a conflict between Danny
and Jon to see which of them is the true
Prince that was promised like they might
have to Duke it out and I think that
could still happen alright moving on
okay we returned to the cave of the
three-eyed Raven and we get this shot of
the dirt slipping through Brand's
fingers and I feel like this could be
foreshadowing the sands of time that are
running out for brand no he doesn't know
it yet but his time in this place is
totally running out and his decision to
go into the vision alone is what
triggers that countdown but notice how
the three-eyed Raven is sleeping and
doesn't stir awake when brand pegs him
with rock I feel like he's letting brand
do this like he knows there's a reason
this has to happen a brand but that's a
theory that I'll get to later so in his
vision bran returns to the same weirwood
tree where we saw the children of the
forest where they created the white
Walker you can see the same overhead
spiral pattern as before except now were
thousands of years later in the present
day and this place has gone from a
colorful world of greens and reds to
this dead snowy graveyard filled with an
army of corpses now this is important
the fact that the White Walkers are here
means that this is way north of the wall
and this land is supposed to be under
constant winter but thousands of years
earlier the place looked like it was the
middle of summer so how is it possible
our theory is that this could mean that
by inventing the White Walkers the
children the forest invented winter the
season itself so from the very beginning
of the show we've assumed that winter is
coming means that White Walkers are
coming but maybe it's the other way
around and the magic that created the
White Walkers is the same magic that
created the climate of Westeros that
we know it to be today but anyway this
mark that the night king gives brand
works like a homing beacon he's giving
his position away to the enemy from
their home base we would tree to the
other great weirwood treat the home base
for the children of the forest and
three-eyed raven
so like the grayscale on George's arm
this mark on brands arm is kind of a
mark of death but if bran is just in a
vision and he's supposed to only be
looking at things how can the night King
see and touch him well what we're
learning here what brands understanding
is that these visions aren't just normal
visions their doors doors that you can
pass through and physically interact
with things on the other side so that's
what brands doing here just like we
almost saw him do with his father at the
tower of joy which we actually have
another theory about I'll get to that
later
bran here is interacting with things in
the past and he can change things or he
already adds changed things so if you're
like me you were wondering if the clock
is ticking right now and night walkers
are on their way to kill them all why
does the three-eyed Raven take Brandon
to another vision instead of just
getting the hell out of there well there
might be a couple reasons why he could
be just expediting branch training
giving him a last-minute crash course in
being a wise old tree man but I think
the three-eyed Raven is also carefully
following a plan he needs bran to
revisit this specific moment of time but
again I'll get to that more later and we
move on to this scene with Sir Davos and
Jon Snow and Sansa strategizing with
this big war map of the north and we've
seen maps like this before with Robb
Stark brooding over the Bolton's and the
umbers and the Karstarks remember back
in season 3 Robb Stark spent a lot of
time trying to figure out how to keep
his northern alliance together even
though it was kind of breaking apart
after he beheaded
Lord Karstark our stark family just
totally split away and now we see that
Rob's sister Sansa and his half-brother
John are having to clean up the mess
that he left planning over another one
of these big maps and trying to put the
pieces back together so a lot of people
were wondering why Sansa lies to sir
Davos and John about how she found out
about the blackfish retaking Riverrun
the reason why I think is that she
doesn't want to admit that Littlefinger
met with her and offered her the help of
the Knights of the Vale
Sansa wants to take back Winterfell but
she doesn't trust Littlefinger she wants
to do it without his help she wants to
go reassemble all the stark bannermen
with
out having a trustus person who
basically sold her into slavery but
what's ironic about this is that santa's
hate for Littlefinger causes her to do
exactly what Littlefinger would do lie
in the situation and cover up the truth
and then we see Sansa taking another
page from Littlefinger's playbook
disguising manipulation in the form of a
gift now we go back to our opening
images and we see what we saw her sewing
in those opening shots a wolf skin cloak
with Stark sigil now this gift to Jon
Snow has two purposes one Sansa knows
that Jon's only as stark bastard so
practically speaking he'll have to look
as much like Ned Stark as possible to
get the northern houses to rally to
their cause but also Sansa wants Jon to
actually embrace his inner stark and
reconnect with his roots just like we've
seen her doing a lot the wolf did the
only thing I want to point out about
this shot of everyone leaving the wall
other than this pig flirty smile between
the bear and his maiden fair is Jon's
goodbye to EDD he says don't look at
them when I'm go now this seems like a
throwaway line but it could be a bigger
deal than it seems
remember the mark on Brandt's arm allows
the night king and the other white
walkers to cross magic barriers the wall
was built 8,000 years ago by brands
namesake bran the Builder to defend the
realm from White Walkers and their
supposedly magic in the wall to keep
White Walkers out but if bran ever goes
south of the wall that could totally
nullify the magic that protects it and
it could end up with the amazing image
of this thing totally collapsing I don't
know if that's gonna be the case it
would be an awesome spectacle but I'll
get back to some wall theories a little
later moving on okay so for this amazing
final sequence so much is going on in
just in case any of you were thinking
what the hell am I seeing right now I'm
gonna do my best to break all of it down
and what I think is going on
so Brandon a three-eyed Raven are in
this vision at Winterfell and it's the
day young Ned Stark leaves for the Vale
to begin his wardship under Jon Arryn
and while they're under the White
Walkers show up led to them by brands
mark Mira tries to escape but odeur
panics and he can't help her so Mira
remembers the times bran has worked into
hodor's mind and she screams down to
bran in the vision to do the same thing
right now
so what brand does is Borg into Willis
remember Willis is Hodor as a young boy
and when he connects the Willises mind
that connects to adores mind in the
future and so through Willis bran is
controlling Hodor like a puppet to save
them so once they get outside mirror
shouts down to Brandon the vision to
make Hodor so they can escape mirror
starts to drag bran away and just like
bad satellite connection the signal
begins to affect Willis his brain his
mind is fused with his future self so
think about this one minute Willis is
just this happy kid working Winterfell
in the next his consciousness just flips
to his old self being chased by these
corpses as his body is out of his
control and then he has to hold a door
while he gets clawed and stabbed by all
these corpses
he literally experiences the pain of his
own death and it's so traumatic and
trippy that it puts him in this state of
shock and he convulses on the ground and
he screams the last words he hears
before his mind is totally fried hold
the door hold the door holds or Hodor
this might be the most heartbreaking
reveal we've ever seen on the show
basically Hodor spends his entire adult
life being mock just so he can one day
sacrifice himself to save brand so it's
hard to watch his death without tearing
up it's also pretty dark because Hodor
isn't consciously sacrificing himself to
say Brandon meera brandon mirror are
making him do it they're forcing their
friend to kill himself
so this is a pretty mind-blowing reveal
right george RR martin has supposedly
been sitting on it for decades
apparently he came up with the idea in
1991 that's five years before the first
book came out
George R Martin has said in an interview
that he wishes he was a faster writer
and he's depressed that the show got to
a reel before the books did but he still
plans to keep hold the door as the
reason motors name is Hodor but he still
is going to introduce in a very
different way so you have a reason to
read the books if you weren't going to
do it already but also fun facts someone
shared an elevator with george RR martin
in 2013 and joke that hodor's name might
come from hold the door and martin joke
you don't know how close to the truth
you are so george RR martin is a pretty
crazy brilliant mastermind who's been
sitting on this specific turn of phrase
for
time whenever I have a plan I have to
say it immediately so I'm gonna dig into
these clothes and images more in a bit
but first I want to try to explain the
time-travel logic that Game of Thrones
is used in here so Phillip kind of went
into this in a previous video talking
about the third Harry Potter movie and
how time is all part of one giant
timeline rather than other theories of
time travel that we've seen like a Back
to the Future where meddling in the past
causes different timelines to form or
changes a timeline in some way Game of
Thrones doesn't look like it's doing
that right now in this version of
time-travel there's only one fixed
timeline and every decision and every
cause and effect is all predestined even
the decision to go back in time and
effect something it's all part of the
big plan this is called a causal loop
also called a self-fulfilling prophecy
think of it as a train track that has
been redirected to loop back to an
earlier part of the track this loop is
still part of the big train track of
Destiny so when you think about it that
way brand started his life on this train
with a simple-minded guy named Hodor who
says Oh d'Or for some reason and it's
not until they're further down the track
that brand goes on that loop realizing
that he was always the reason Hodor is
the way he is
it wasn't Rance decision to change that
track he was just along for the ride now
I know this is super confusing and to be
honest I don't fully understand it and a
lot of you guys are asking if the
three-eyed Raven knew all of this was
going to happen why would he even let
brand go into a vision where the night
king would mark him and why would he
just not let brand wake up from this
vision and warg into adulthood or so he
doesn't ruin voters brain as a kid this
self-fulfilling prophecy of time-travel
kind of explains why the three-eyed
Raven can't alter the track he's kind of
like the train conductor he knows what
the stops are it's his job to make sure
brand gets where he needs to be
specifically bran needs to be with young
Willis on the day he loses his mind
because that's all part of destiny
mission trio friend Brendan so the
question isn't what else will bran
change its what else has brand already
changed right so there's a theory out
there that brand could be the reason
that the mad king went mad to begin with
or bran was the voice Arya heard back in
the first book when she killed the
stableboy in King's Landing or that bran
could be bran the Builder himself
in fact one part of the books mentions a
small boy told the men and the children
of the forest how to build the wall and
that that boy grew up to be bran the
Builder though if brand time-travel is
behind all the big historical events of
Westeros it kind of takes some of the
fun out of the world that george RR
martin created so i kind of hope that
they limit the amount of times that bran
could have affected things but there is
one brand theory based off of what we've
already seen that's got me thinking
let's take another look at that Tower of
joy moment I referenced earlier I wonder
when brand shouted at Ned Stark he gave
Ned Stark the idea to pretend to be the
father to the baby that he finds up in
the tower
probably Jon Snow now it's just a theory
don't quote me on it but it's definitely
true it's just a theory probably true
now I've been talking a lot about the
specifics of time travel and what's
happening when bran is working into
Willis into Hodor but there's a lot
that's happening in the sequence it's
also intense and well-directed and
there's a bunch of other details I want
to point out first
Hodor is not the only person who dies to
save brand pretty much everyone does
lief uses this Holy Hand Grenade to blow
herself up in the tunnel and the
three-eyed Raven pulls an obi-wan Kenobi
letting the night King strike them down
hopefully to become more powerful than
ever before and most sadly we say
goodbye to another dire wolf summer four
out of the six stark dire wolves are now
dead leaving only ghosts into merio
alive but unlike the others summer at
least goes out fighting also summers
name seems important here right like the
death the summer means the beginning of
winter and Starks are more prepared for
winter than any other family so summers
death could just be another natural step
in the year of stark either way our ap
summer we
hardly knew you also I know some of you
guys were wondering about the White
Walkers and the whites and why some of
them could pass through the fire while
others couldn't now remember White
Walkers are the supernatural beings that
were created by the children of the
forest with obsidian dragonglass
so while obsidian can kill them along
with Valyrian steel they're totally cool
with fire whites are the zombie like
corpses that they control obsidian and
Valyrian steel can cut them up but fire
is really the only true way you can
destroy them but the bigger question I
have is how will these creatures deal
with dragon fire I don't know if dragon
glass is created maybe by dragon fire
and if dragons are making the way to
Westeros it'd be interesting to see
these two supernatural beings showdown
against each other we'll see but let's
get back to these closing images
remember this episode is called the door
which is obviously a reference to Hodor
holding the door in the final moments
but Hodor isn't just holding a literal
door he's holding a door open to the
past this episode checks in with a lot
of characters but at the center of it
are three of the stark children Sansa
Arya and bran and each of them walk
through portals in time to reexamine
traumatic experiences as they need to
learn from Sansa store brings her back
to Ramsay's cruelty but she learns the
strength to stand up to another man who
treated her like an object Littlefinger
Arya's dora takes her back to the moment
that started her journey the execution
of her father at baylor but she learns
that the version of events that she
experienced isn't the same truth that
the rest of the world believes and of
course brands dora shows how he caused
his friends psychotic breakdown and
death but he needs his experience to
learn that he has the power to influence
past events or he has already influenced
past events Hodor is a tragic figure and
the big reveal come in at the moment of
his death is such a gut punch but his
death serves a greater purpose he saves
bran while simultaneously allowing him
to understand an important part of his
powers and Hodor does this all in a
simple act of holding the door okay so
here's the part where Phil wants me to
take a look at the preview for the next
episode and make some predictions so
next episode is called blood of my blood
and just in case any of these
predictions into being right they could
be pretty big spoilers so snip past this
part if you don't want to know anything
okay here we go so we see a few shots of
bran and Meera alone in the woods
freaking out as the whites are closing
in on them
and a few of you guys are wondering
where episode 5 let these two like they
aren't exactly safe at all they've lost
some are the dire wolf and Hodor and
those badass children of the forest with
their awesome grenades so who's gonna
protect them now they obviously need
help well I have a theory on this the
trailer for season 6 showed a quick shot
of someone that I'm pretty sure is an
awesome character from the books his
name is cold hands cold hands is a
mysterious masked figure who's part
white maybe part X brother of the Nights
Watch
maybe he rides this awesome massive elk
and somehow he's kind of a good guy he
saves Sam in book 3 and later on a book
5 he's the one who guides Brandon the
three-eyed Raven so I have a feeling
that the show's gonna bring him in brand
together next episode maybe hopefully
and again this is a possible spoiler but
there is a popular Ferenc theory that
cold hands is actually the missing
benjin start remember if we go back to
brands vision there was this long shot
of young benjin dark back in the
flashback as Ned Stark hugged him
goodbye so the show is reminding us of
benjin for a reason also george RR
martin has denied the rumors that benjin
is Coldhands but either way i feel like
we're gonna see benjin come back in some
form at some point this season we also
see some shots of Sam and Gilly at the
Tarly home city of horn Hill as well as
this guy Lord randyll Tarly now a little
history on Randall he fought on the
losing side of Robert's rebellion but he
actually forced Robert's army to retreat
at the Battle of Ashford
but Robert ended up winning the war
anyway leaving Randall to become this
surly [ __ ] that his son Sam has
described him as feel like he's not
gonna be cool with Sam keeping a
wildling under its roof we'll see how
long they last there there's also this
footage of the big showdown between the
Tyrells and the faith militant in King's
Landing
now our previous videos predicted that
this might not go exactly as Jamie and
Cersei proposed that it would but by the
look of Jamie's upset reaction I feel
like this is going to blow up in their
faces remember the high Sparrow is a
master manipulator he always has an ace
up his sleeve and I feel like this isn't
going to turn out well for the
Lannisters so finally we get this
interesting shot of Daenerys leading the
Dothraki through these dusty desert
hills now this reminds me of that Sun
rising in the West promised that
it always comes back to part of that
phrases when the Seas go dry when the
mountains blow in the wind like leaves
now the dust blowing off these mountains
fits that description pretty well also
notice how Dario calls Daenerys of
Conqueror conqueror denounced on blonde
now I know this is probably a stretch
but every time I hear her and Conqueror
used to describe a Targaryen I feel like
it's gotta be a reference to Aegon the
Conqueror that's the first Targaryen to
jump on a dragon and fly across the
Narrow Sea to conquer Westeros and crown
himself Lord of the Seven Kingdoms now
the reason I bring this up is we know
drogon is lying around somewhere we
haven't seen him at all this season let
me know what you think about this okay
finally let's get to our lingering
questions so what does this mean for
brands power now he's not connected to
the weirwood tree but he's still kind of
in this vision in this trance so does
this mean he can see through time
remotely just like how he can control
animals remotely when and wherever he
wants also that mark from the night king
that's on his arm is it stay with him
everywhere he goes is he always going to
be on the run from now on is he just
gonna be constantly chased by this army
of White Walkers I don't know that that
would be pretty terrifying and also a
pretty huge pain in the ass for Mara who
has to drag him everywhere also do we
think Sansa did the right thing by
refusing Littlefinger's help and turning
down the Knights of the Vale I mean
they're pretty massive army and they
desperately need more men to take back
Winterfell also do you think she should
have lied to Jon Snow and Sir Thomas
about it III don't really know it seems
like there's something that she did it
of pride but she has a very valid reason
to not trust Littlefinger we'll just
have to see if she has enough men on her
side to not need his help okay that's it
that's everything I got let me know what
you think of all this in the comments
thanks so much for watching these please
go easy on me in the comments it's the
first time I've really done one of these
so I'm just trying to fill in and help
Philip as he feels better and minces
broken heart you'd like this video
please share it around and of course
like it and subscribe to new rockstars
for more videos also make sure to check
out our other episode breakdowns Phillip
went into a lot of fan theories and
those last ones so I didn't cover
something here Phillip probably went
over it in one of those other videos you
can follow us on twitter at new rock
stars you can hit up Phillip with more
questions on
at fimo or you can follow him on
Facebook complex fimo nose alright guys
thanks for watching I'm Erik Bosse bite
you